Danny Hero two Gs news update but we've  just seen the latest Raider for Call of  Duty advanced warfare and inish a first  look at EXO survival co-op mode well we  knew this Call of Duty would include  co-op but until now we didn't know any  details EXO survival mode appears to be  a wave based mode where you and three  others hold off different types of  enemies it would be a safe assumption  that the waves will become more and more  difficult  reminiscent of years of wars classic  horde mode or firefight from Halo ODST  right now it is unknown if there will be  other co-op modes or if there will be a  co-op campaign advanced warfare comes  out on November 4th on Xbox 360 Xbox one  PlayStation 3 ps4 and PC for more  detailed analysis of call duty advanced  warfare including a trailer breakdown  we're gonna post pretty soon go to  GameSpot calm for it slash news